keine ahnung wollte ich habe super sic
beseitigen drin sehe nichts unter vom
hacker verfolgt oder verschenkt
alle vier
servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute mal wieder ins
amt liegt nach langer zeit wie ich habe
wieder markt dabei und heute haben wir
eine challenge die in absolutes chaos
ausarten wird definitiv oder und müssen
eine unsichtbare ändert es und zwar die
kombination aus super secret settings
die euch sehr gut gefallen hat challenge
und ab wechselt ständig das heißt wir
werden heute sowohl nach jedem jump
verein als super secret settings
rettinghaus als auch jetzt geht schon
los uns nach abschluss jedes moduls
abwechseln und jetzt gibt es das
superding 1 es sieht recht komisch aus
es geht
das geht eher ist es ist definitiv
spielbar ja ist schon mal wichtig
bisschen ein bisschen schlechtere ok ich
hab' ich finde dieses wenn man wenn sie
alles zu verzieht dass da kannst du
nichts machen sie wenn sie alles was man
hier wenn das so ein florierender so
unkontrollierbar bot das bild passt so
was gibt und dass du dich bewegst woche
das ja da kann es ganz vergessen
berlin setting das unspielbar war okay
erste gute chance halbiert wenn man zu
den arbeiten du kannst es schaffen
ja es geht voll aus eigentlich auch noch
mal gleich hast du daraus gemacht
ich weiß nicht wie man darauf an wo
zweimal klicken einfach einmal einmal
drauf klicken so jetzt nicht fasste ich
genau so beschäftigen
ihr könnt ihr geduld einziges nein und
ich habe mir die physikerin marie mävers
war bis jetzt das die drug perspektive
gehen wieder die drogen perspektive
games es normal aus also bei maxxim
aufdrucken ist und das geht zu erklären
in trossingen ja meist und kommt bei
macy's ist natürlich deutlich über dem
wald kloppen zu passiv wird weil wir
auch noch die super secret steuerung
haben für in meinem fall war sebastian
in eine andere steuern als ich hatte
also die mein mann spielt ihr nach einer
gewissen zeit minecraft schon intuitiv
und mein bruder hat einfach sprinten und
snacken aus meiner sicht vertauscht
ich habe sprinten aufschriften auf
steuerung max hat das auf default
nämlich auf steuerung und es liegen auf
schiffen ins alte weiter geht's das geld
das ging jetzt gut es ging ja es ist
geht auch ein leser es gibt ja diese
super sic settings die sind für die
optik ein bisschen gar nicht gesehen
das geht aber das ist ja besser wurde
extra kontur an alle blöcke oder sowas
das erinnert mich an mir früher diese
samsung-handy versierte hatte dies
schiebehandy es hatte so ein paar
lustige effekte drin die man ich weiß
wir kleine sterben nicht das 0 1 ein
ganz vorne
weiters wird checken wir sind nah oder
all die schnell sind die diesen diesen
mega hinten dran aber es geht wie immer
auf 38 punkte
die sind einfach insgesamt relativ gut
aber wir sind eigentlich vor allem das
war ich nahe
alles klar aber scheinen aber ist schon
voll lustig das ist blacky voll cool aus
soll ich mein kann also die sein wenn ja
schreibt es erinnert mich an die dings
ich weiß nicht gleich noch diese
erkenntnis module nicht mal wieder raus
manchmal spielen ich bin aber schon
wieder abgespielt so schnell alles klar
aus dem fenster sowie ein regina
herunter ich war auch mal ein kleines
stück gespräche aber sogar wie unsere
oma wir gerade im konsum familien
kaffeeklatsch kommen ihr wisst ja
weihnachten ja natürlich weil walter dix
hessisch für alle die von außen kommen
von euch kennen und genau jetzt auf den
daraus den daraus genau das aber nicht
daraus habe ich ja genau
und gleich werdet nicht der kommt nicht
recht rüber und hier und jetzt und jetzt
vorsichtig die wichtige perspektive das
steuer von wischiwaschi stollhammer
wissen wie es ist ja ok hatte sturm ist
gewaltig die stelle kurz von deadline
noch einmal super setting war
schnellster die mischung mache jetzt auf
jeden fall will ich sagen es soll ich
zum letzten mal auch gemacht
assad müsse aufpassen dürfen nicht
erfüllt denn erfinders benutzen
immer wenn er fünf modus benutzt geht
das setting weg um ihr spiel hatte ich
auch ohne optimal weil auch die feier
goutiert sogar gar keins ist wieder ein
bisschen komisch auskommen
den kopf man ja ist ja alles klar
allerdings erschwert dungeon keeper
online schon wieder der herr kummer
wieder dreißigste computex zu frechen
ist so fucking fresh alter ok hat einen
richtig bösen aber keine chance wobei
eigentlich war aber wir nehmen es ja
auch wenn es auf also leute vom planet
tüten teamplayer hat schreibt in die
kommentare
wer von euch machte minecraft hätten ja
der glocke blogger einfach was ist das
teil auf den kopf schon passt kann sein
dass der platz komplett verhagelt
hacker douglas ich erstmal über leidigen
einfacher machen ich mache mache ich
entdecke dich und schreibe aufzuwecken
lässt das verrate ich nicht nein
wie das ok 55 benutzen
aber was ich denn der spielt glaube ich
der chip kann
das ist seht ihr denn haare hatte das
passiert wenn man nicht spielt alles
klar
das ist ungefähr so dass das schlimmste
direkt malta ich muss sagen das ist das
schönste direkt nach alt da war hacker
nein ich mache internet rein
ok
tennis
mindestens der größte stärke und nicht
aber arbeitet er hat den meister zsc spd
gefällt mir
wir haben ok eingeholt so getting ready
to row aber dass juristen zeit
lächerlich ich hab' ich hoffe ich kurz
mal den jetzt dafür zweimal finden naja
es ist sozusagen wieder einen job zu job
und wir können auf ihr fahrrad unbedingt
auf wir können es fachkräften was jeff
kathrein kfw-chef die gute ja das habe
ich noch nie gesehen ist hätte hier dass
es dieses blut für mich nicht das habe
ich selbst noch nie gesehen halte er
kann mega viele fall raus aber wollen 84
respekt aber im kern bogen
der hat sich die partnerin bogen in der
kiste ja das ist längst weg
ich würd sagen und eisberg der gehört
noch drei hat der hacker hat noch drei
leben es gibt noch einen anderen weg
körpers kommt können wir etwas machen
junge ich hab eiskaltes wasser nicht
gesehen man sieht dem alter das ist
ungefähr das mieseste secret setting ich
sage das ist es dann auch ein hinter dir
der andrea heute wisse hätte keine fünf
keine 5 durch die software kann da ich
selber habe noch gilt aber der ist ja
oder kam ich dann okay hacker blogs box
machen und zu warten weiterhin nur wo
man hin will ja ich hab keine ahnung ich
habe super setting drin kennst du die
kas sehen nichts unter vom hacker
verfolgt oder fragt die karten kenne so
halbwegs ja alles alle auf einmal ist er
da du mist geburt leute das was von
dieser challenge wunderbar dass wir noch
länger warten das hat die einfach
unmöglich gemacht wenn ihr schild nach
setzt euch jetzt vor dem bildschirm und
guckt so auf einem bildschirm
tschüss